[Música]
y llegamos a la revista de prensa hoy
viernes la última revista de prensa de
esta semana ya está conmigo en el
estudio rosa pérez masdéu rosa
bienvenida bonita a la luna no la
pudimos ver desde la redacción aquí es
france24 pero bueno vamos a hablar de lo
que nos compete el espectador de
colombia policías de turba se le
forjaron vistiéndose de militares de la
alemania nazi yo la verdad no sé si
reírme llorar con esta noticia rosa es
reír por no llorar raúl
exacto son unas imágenes que han dado la
vuelta a colombia recordemos es lo que
lo que muestran estas imágenes son la
celebración de la semana de la
internalización de la escuela de policía
simón bolívar de tuluá en que pues sea
los agentes decidieron a celebrar esta
semana ambientándola en nada más y nada
menos que la alemania nazi y tal y como
describe el espectador esvásticas
disfraces de la gestapo policía secreta
de la alemania nazi una réplica del
histórico avión de la luz suave letras
en alemán uno de los uniformados
se vistió de hitler aquí lo vemos aquí
detrás en otra imagen se ve más
claramente
bien y de hecho estas imágenes raúl una
de las cosas fuertes de estos hechos es
que fue la propia policía que la subió a
sus redes sociales acompañándolo del
siguiente texto con estos intercambios
culturales fortalecemos el conocimiento
de nuestros estudiantes de policía bien
esto como comentábamos se sucedió en tu
lugar pero la dirección de las escuelas
de policía condenó los hechos ya ha
dicho que han despedido al director de
esta escuela y también han pedido
excusas públicas tanto a la comunidad
judía como a todo aquello que se haya
podido sentir ofendido también han
condenado los hechos tanto la embajada
de alemania como la de israel a quien
colombiano condenado esta apología del
nazismo y es que tal y como recuerda el
espectador raúl aquí en colombia en la
apología del genocidio está tipificado
como un delito
rosa seguimos en colombia la silla vacía
ganó su tercer premio cabo eso es esta
queríamos hacer referencia a este medio
colombiano también porque ha ganado el
premio este cabo de periodismo a la
innovación por la forma en que ha
llevado a cabo esta investigación
comprobando vídeos que circularon por
las redes sociales la localización de
los hechos que aparecen en estos vídeos
y gracias a esta investigación han
podido probar que fueron policías los
que mataron a tres jóvenes de verbena
aquí en bogotá durante las protestas de
2020 y de hecho los policías que mataron
a andrés felipe rodríguez haider fonseca
están imputados por homicidio sin
embargo el que mató a cristian hernández
no ha podido ser identificado sea como
sea queremos felicitar a estos
compañeros colombianos tanto por el
premio como por esta labor y esta
contribución a la justicia
felicitaciones a estos ganadores rosa
como bien lo decías vamos ahora con
carta capital de brasil triunfo del
ecocidio evolucionario especialistas y
políticos reaccionan
ante la deforestación
exacto hemos querido
seleccionar este medio brasileño y
también este medio francés porque a
titulan con lo mismo así como distintos
periódicos de alrededor del mundo porque
se han dado a conocer las cifras de
deforestación del último año el estudio
realizado entre agosto de 2020 y julio
de 2021 que indica que se ha batido un
nuevo récord en el aumento de la tasa de
deforestación de la amazonía son unas
cifras que no se registraban desde 2006
y de hecho raúl en este último año la
explotación forestal ha acabado con
13.000 235 kilómetros cuadrados de
amazonía lo que es más que la propia es
superficial del líbano y tanto lo que
destaca carta capital como lo mont es
que el tanto la sociedad civil como la
comunidad científica y política acusa al
gobierno de bolsonaro de esconder estas
cifras durante la cop 26 cuando ya las
tenía en el despacho y de hecho también
recalca unas declaraciones que hizo el
presidente de brasil
este mismo lunes en que aseguró que el
90 por ciento de la amazonía está
intacta citando sus palabras dijo que
tal y como fue descubierto brasil en
1500 pero los últimos estudios señalan
que ya raúl se ha acabado con casi el 20
por ciento de la amazonía que el 19 por
ciento ya está completamente destruida
usted lo comentaba a lemon en brasilia
la deforestación de la amazonía se
acelera todavía más a rosa si es lo que
lo que veníamos comentando que tanto el
mont como distintos vídeos
internacionales pues se hacen eco de
estas cifras alarman vamos ahora a
hablar de la revista 'time' el metaverso
ya ha llegado esto es lo que realmente
significa el artículo orizo picture
alinco art si este artículo es muy útil
le animamos a cualquier persona que le
interese entender de lo que estamos
hablando cuando mencionamos el metaverso
porque es muy ilustrativo y comenta las
aplicaciones que ya tiene no esté pues
el universo está fusión de lo que es la
vida física con la vida virtual y pone
como distintos ejemplos juegos de avatar
es que pues se permite en una ampliación
de lo que concedemos como las relaciones
humanas también ponen ejemplos de
personas que ya trabajan inmersas en el
mundo virtual el ejemplo de un ejecutivo
que trabajan las 8 horas del días
inmerso en un casco de realidad virtual
en el que tiene todo su escritorio pero
plantea raúl que tenemos ya de hecho en
ciertos problemas de los temas por
resolver en el internet que ya tenemos
que es así como la propiedad de los
datos en la regulación el hackeo el
crimen organizado en internet y que
antes de ampliar este mundo digital
deberíamos empezar a regular el que ya
tenemos bueno nos vemos entonces en el
metaverso cuando ya pues salga una
aplicación buena para tener ahí nuestros
avatares las gracias a toda la
información feliz fin de semana llevarle
paso en este primer invita al día
[Música]